[Music]
the glitter looks that I created it the
autumn/winter shows it was this sort of
like festival girl basically I just a
blue glitter onto their faces and you
can either take a moisturizer or a
Vaseline and that will give the glitter
something to adhere to if you want it to
last the whole night of the party you
could also use eyelash glue now
sometimes people go like eyelash glue on
the eyes well why not
you put eyelash glue on the lash line of
your eye to apply lash so it's perfectly
safe to put it all over the lid but do
remember to wait till the eyelash glue
goes clear before you apply your product
and then you know it will last all night
[Music]
the best way to remove it is to use an
oil cleanser I really like Xuan aura oil
cleanser and I also like the deco or oil
cleanser I have been known to do 14
shows back to back in London invariably
I'll do sort of like six to eight in
each city like New York London Milan
Paris
the most incredible mascara ever and not
only is um is it a mascara that curls it
also it has this funny little sort of
like flippy bit so you can really sort
of like it right into the corners but it
really does lengthen and curl I love
that product well you can always add
more and you can always take it off as
well to just have to use colored mascara
you know one of the trends that I sort
of like feel that's around at the moment
it's like using more than one colored
mascara on your eyelashes my beauty rule
is wearing no makeup is a missed
opportunity even a little makeup is
brightener everybody needs a brightener
[Music]